sind unverständlich der mann ist ja auch
gefährdet und die zumutung für die
anwohner darüber ist ja auch schon
gesprochen worden die ist natürlich groß
auf der anderen seite wollen wir
riskieren dass ausgerechnet hier bei uns
dem amerikanischen präsidenten etwas
passiert nein das wollen wir nicht viel
bedauerlicher finde ich dass die bürger
in berlin von diesem empfang abgehalten
werden man kann ihm ja quasi fast
nirgends vorsehen
und das ist eigentlich doch sehr sehr
schade auch dieses ist natürlich
offiziell den sicherheitsvorkehrungen
geschuldet allerdings erinnere ich mal
daran dass andere präsidenten wie zum
beispiel bill clinton im jahr 19 94 vor
50.000 gesprochen haben auf dem pariser
platz
aber da gab es ja auch nine eleven noch
nicht so und nun sehen wir es diese
schwere tür wird aufgemacht und da
schütteln sich die beiden präsidenten
die hand wie gesagt sie kennen sich
nicht in dieser minute
haben sie sich das erste mal hier
getroffen
das ist jetzt der bildtermin den ich
angesprochen habe
johann georg freut sich auch dass er dem
gast so ein schönes wetter hier bieten
kann
das war ja weiß gott in diesem sommer
nicht immer so aber pünktlich zum
erscheinen des amerikanischen
präsidenten hier hochsommer stimmung in
berlin hoffentlich färbt das dann auch
auf die politischen gespräche ab wir
sehen jetzt hier die eingangshalle im
schloss bellevue jetzt joachim gauck hat
das gefühl die grafen müssen noch mal zu
einem bild kommen sehr schönes bild hier
beide nochmal winkend und sich freuen
und ganz interessant in der
eingangshalle steht normalerweise der
tisch mit dem gästebuch des herrn
bundespräsidenten
fragen sie mich nicht aber dieser tisch
ist weggeräumt worden
die beiden gehen jetzt ein bisschen
umständlich der hintere tür die sie
jetzt sehen das wäre eigentlich die
galerie wo das gästebuch bereit liegt
man geht jetzt aber durch den garten
salon das ist der raum den sie jetzt
betreten
anschließend durchläuft man den
damensalon und geht dann in die galerie
ich kann lediglich vorstellen dass die
in der galerie postierten journalisten
genau vor der tür stehen jetzt hier
rechts neben dem eingangsbereich da ist
die galerie diese vier fenster die sie
da sehen sind glaub ich sogar 5 dahinter
stehen natürlich auch wieder kollegen
mit kameras und fotografen allerdings
viel weniger als hier draußen das wird
geprügelt nennen wir das also das bild
wird dann für alle zur verfügung
gestellt und warum man diesen umweg in
dem schloss macht bin ich mir nicht ganz
sicher die räumlichkeiten sind zwar sehr
hübsch ist es ja auch restauriert worden
dieses schloss im jahre 2004 und 2005
aber so schön sind sie denn auch nicht
dass man hier die ehrenrunde dreht bin
mir nicht ganz sicher warum man das
gemacht hat aber hinter diesen fenstern
wird gleich der eintrag in das gästebuch
des bundespräsidenten stattfinden
ja und hier wie gesagt sammeln sich
jetzt die fotografen die während der
unterschrift offensichtlich aber
umdrehen nein sie dürfen natürlich nicht
dadurch sie müssen außen rum gehen wie
man auch nicht sicher ob das die
gleichen kollegen sind die nachher im
park dabei sein wenn im park übrigens
sind gar nicht so viele menschen bei den
militärischen ehren anwesens lediglich
die amtsangehörigen und 29 schüler der
john f kennedy schule aus
berlin-zehlendorf die im dezember 1963
gegründet wurde nach der ermordung von
john f kennedy eine institution in
berlin diese schule hat übrigens im
gegensatz zu den berliner kindern heute
noch keine schulferien heute fangen hier
nämlich von die ferien an sondern erst
in zwei wochen aber heute gibt es
schulfrei für die kinder in der john-f
-kennedy-schule jetzt also die
unterschrift
und da war der präsident scheint
zufrieden der präsident muss ich sagen
war obama in dem fall sicher beides
präsidenten noch mal die hand
geschüttelt
nach dem militärischen ehren werden sie
sich zu einem gespräch in das amtszimmer
des bundespräsidenten zurückziehen das
ist kein vieraugengespräch da sind
einige delegationsteilnehmer dabei und
dieses gespräch wird dann natürlich ohne
kameras statt finden
jetzt kommen gleich wie gesagt für den
offiziellen teil der veranstaltung heute
morgen schon hier das vorgefahren
stabsmusikkorps unter walter rats
führung er ist seit dem november 2012
der chef des stabsmusikkorps es 80
musiker werden hier heute an treten auch
dass zum beispiel zu einem großen
staatsempfang ein unterschied die zahl
der musiker
man könnte auf 110 aufbieten aber bei
einem offiziellen besuch läuft das ganze
ein bisschen kleiner habe interessant
übrigens noch beim großen staatsbesuch
der dauert mehrere tage
der jeweilige der hier deutschland
besucht legt dann auch einen kranz in
der neuen wache nieder
es gibt also ganz verschiedene
programmpunkte
aber das ist eigentlich alles nur fürs
protokoll
der amerikanische präsident besucht hier
bei herrlichstem wetter dieses
wunderbare schöne schloss bellevue
das sich im besten lichte präsentiert
oben sehen sie die standarte auch so
eine geschichte über die es viele
geheimnis gibt die oben auf dem schloss
lädt die weht immer dann wenn der
bundespräsident in deutschland ist es
wenn er im ausland weilt wird sie
eingeholt
oder wenn er in seiner zweiten sitz
villa hammerschmidt in bonn ist so jetzt
sind wir auf den bereich der gartenseite
und gleich wird also das militärische
zeremoniell vonstatten gehen natürlich
gehört das loch das wachbataillon der
bundeswehr aber zunächst wird hier erst
einmal die popularität die deutsche
delegation wird jetzt hier
darunter zum beispiel der staatssekretär
osten auswirken
aber auch der stadt wird er hier
bundespräsident
dann mehrere protokolle offiziere
300 mann hat alleine das auswärtige amt
in der protokollabteilung nicht alle
sind mit dem jetzigen besucher fasst
aber doch viele das ist natürlich eine
große logistische herausforderung und
jetzt das ganze umgekehrt
jetzt bekommt also joachim gauck die
amerikanische delegation vorgestellt die
ist übrigens vier vorhin einschließlich
der white house press vor gefahren
worden ich konnte die busse kaum zählen
ich glaube es waren neun an der zahl es
ist eine sehr große delegation mit dem
präsidenten hier gereist
die wir natürlich jetzt hier in der
reihe nicht alle vorgestellt auch das
ist protokollarisch genau festgelegt wer
hier an vorgestellt wird und wenn sie
vermissen die lebensgefährtin des
bundespräsidenten auch das ist
fotocollage logisch da barack obama ohne
seine gattin hier vor gefahren ist ist
auch die lebensgefährtin des
bundespräsidenten hier heute nicht dabei
da hinten sehen wir jetzt das
wachbataillon bereits angetreten
alle drei truppeneinheiten so ist das
üblich der kommandeur oberstleutnant
michael chrobok dieses wach bataillon
stellt ja verschiedene anforderungen an
seine soldaten
sie dürfen weder brille noch bärte
tragen und auch sehr schön ist dass die
kopf paarung festgelegt wird die länge
muss mindestens sechs und zwölf
millimeter aufweisen
und jetzt werden die nationalhymnen
zunächst folgen wie das üblich ist
exzellenz ich melde die ehrenformation
der bundeswehr zu ihrer begrüßung
angetreten
hd
aus
ja
staatspleiten jetzt die abordnung das
ist so üblich vielleicht hatten sie
zwischendurch auch einige bild ausfälle
so wie ich das muss ich entschuldigen
wir übernehmen hier das bild von
kollegen der transportweg scheint dass
sie länger zu sein die ein oder andere
verbindung hat vielleicht nicht so
richtig gesteckt aber jetzt zunächst
also hier das abschreiben
ich habe wird sie hatten keinen
bildausfall da haben sie es besser
gehabt als ich hier nochmal etwas lange
chrobok die abmeldung nächster
programmpunkt jetzt die beiden sogar
schon arm in arm hier wie gesagt wir
haben sich das erste mal getroffen
scheint aber von anfang an hier die
chemie zu stimmen und ich ergänze mal
kein wunder hier bei diesem herrlichen
wetter und ich hatte es schon einmal
angedeutet die menschen die sie da
hinten sehen das sind vor allen dingen
amts angehörige aber auch hier die
schüler die wir jetzt sehen von der john
f kennedy schule aus den sechsten
klassen wurden ausgelost 5 pro klasse
sodass 30 schüler hier seien hätten
können aber ein schüler ist leider
erkrankt insofern sind 29
für sie sicherlich ein riesengroßer tag
nicht alle von ihnen sind amerikaner
die deutsch auch auf dieser schule aber
hier dem amerikanischen präsidenten dem
deutschen bundespräsidenten wahl die an
zu finden das natürlich ein höhepunkt
sicherlich auch im leben eines
zwölfjährigen das ist doch klar
und während die beiden präsidenten hier
also sich um die jugend kümmern schöne
bilder natürlich für die kameras sind
teile der zweiten generation schon
einmal in das amtszimmer des herrn
bundespräsidenten vorangeschritten und
werden dort schon platz nehmen denn das
gespräch was gleich folgt immerhin hat
man sich 45 minuten wird man sich zeit
nehmen für die lose gespräche dieses
gespräch ist kein vieraugengespräch
sondern neben der dolmetscherin sind zum
beispiel auch die staatssekretäre der
beiden nationale sicherheitsberater die
beiden botschafter für wir überlegen
länder also man sitzt da ein größerer
runde man darf gespannt sein nachdem
diese bilde dir ja die große harmonie
den beiden zeigen ob dieses gespräch
zwischen ähnlich ablaufen glaube ich
wobei das thema von joachim gauck völlig
klar ist freiheit sind menschenrechte
und ich nehme mal an so willmann jahren
kennengelernt hat bereits
bundespräsident wird er sicherlich auch
in einem internen gespräch kernsatz
gewinnen und sie durch den präsidenten
auch über die vorfälle sprechen
die frage ist big brother is watching
you ich nehme an dass das einen
bürgerrechtler joachim gauck sicherlich
auch interessieren wird man muss
natürlich auch die diplomatischen
gepflogenheiten nicht überschreiten also
massive kritik an den amerikanern ist
von seiten des deutschen
bundespräsidenten sicherlich nicht zu
erwarten aber ich glaube schon dass er
da mal nachfragen wird und war obama
kann dann ja schon mal üben denn so ist
wie angekündigt die bundeskanzlerin wird
nachher im kanzleramt sicherlich dieses
thema auch mit dem amerikanischen
präsidenten besprechen die beiden gehen
also jetzt wieder hier in das schloss
bellevue gleich das erste zimmer rechts
das ist das amtszimmer des deutschen
bundespräsidenten und dort wird er eben
jetzt mit barack obama dem 44
präsidenten amerikas wird der elfte
bundespräsident deutschland so auch ganz
schön dieses zahlenspiel wird also hier
gleich das gespräch beginnen
punkt 10 uhr 55 so ist geplant soll hier
die abreise sein nachdem man eben schon
etwas verspätet war bin ich mir da nicht
mehr ganz so sicher aber ich glaube wir
sollten dann wieder hier vorbeischauen
während jetzt hier die information bei
dreht und das schloss bellevue wieder
verlässt
und wir hier noch einmal von außen die
bilder des amtszimmer sehen da sitzen
jetzt also einige menschen zusammen
auf jeder seite ca 10
holen würde ich sagen dass wir hier von
diesen herrlichen schuss baby 1 lag es
ja weit vor den toren berlins
mittlerweile liegt es hier mitten in der
stadt im tiergarten bellevue schöne
aussicht übrigens der berliner sagt ja
ganz liebevoll bälle wieder zu diese
schöne aussicht hat früher prinz
ferdinand vor einigen nach hinten raus
also auf der anderen seite wo ich nicht
schwer genossen dieser herrliche park
der erstreckte sich kilometerweit
jetzt sehen wir genau innen drin die
beiden präsidenten hier am runden tisch
hin
drum rum die delegationen das ist ja so
üblich bisher noch ein lockeres motor
man wird sicherlich auch warten bis die
kameras aus dem raum sind bevor man sich
dann ernsthaft unter hell wie ernsthaft
das können wir dann wahrscheinlich gar
nicht rausfliegen da solche gespräche
werden auch im nachhinein eigentlich
nicht der öffentlichkeit zugänglich
gemacht aber ich habe ja schon dass
meine dazu gesagt ich nehme schon an
dass joachim gauck auch ein gepflegtes
wort zu der aktuellen situation
verlieren dürfte ja also ich hab gesagt
er schön auf der schöne blick nach
hinten der erstreckte sich damals
kilometerweit mittlerweile ist ja nach
einiger zeit schluss da steht das
viadukt die s-bahn 1880 eingebaut dem
wechsel ein bisschen verstellt und
während wir jetzt hier noch einmal das
amtszimmer von der gartenseite